MAN (VOICEOVER): But
even here, there's
no escape from the storm.
I have to get out of
this freezing wind.
Best I can do is just find a
quick shelter behind the wind
shadow of these trees.
[wind howling]
I dig down through the snow
at the base of a spruce,
making a hole just big
enough to fit myself into.
Snow is the key to
keeping warm out here.
Fresh snow is up
to 95% trapped air,
and that air acts as
a powerful insulator--
trapping heat and
preventing it from escaping.
That's why the Cree keep it
up around their temporary
shelters, and why many
animals survived the winters
buried in snow caves.
By digging down into
the snow like this
and then using my
snowshoes to create a roof,
I'm not only protecting
myself from the wind,
but creating an
insulated air pocket
where I can try to stay warm.
All I can do is hunker down
and wait for the storm to pass.
[music playing]
Priority right now is
to keep myself warm.
If this storm goes
on until dark,
I won't be able to build
a shelter or light a fire.
And without them, I will not
survive through the night.
[music playing]